peut-être autre chose
ladies and gentlemen good evening mais
là messieurs bonsoir
suite de notre journée anglaise après
l'après midi composé par claude guinard
et avant notre programme de la soirée
choisi par ailleurs chancelle voici donc
un journal al anglaise et non pas
seulement en direct de londres nous
avons choisi de jouer complètement le
jeu de nous fixer dans le cadre de la
bbc d'adopter leur style et qui sait
leurs tics
vous verrez c'est un type de journal
très sobre sans nos caméras sont
diapositives derrière moi mais nous
avons décidé de ne pas tricher d'être
fair-play comme on dit ici pour ce faire
je serai assisté de ma consoeur anglaise
angela weepu est très populaire en
grande-bretagne et qui fait le même
métier que moi depuis trois ans voilà
pour la forme sur le fond bien sûr nous
ne négligerons aucune information de
france mais la coloration des nouvelles
sera forcément plus europe et en france
donc l'actualité numéro un c'est
l'arrestation de six membres de l'armée
républicaine bretonne clandestine fondé
il ya deux ans des cendres du slb un
gros coup de filet qui fait suite à
l'attentât contre le château de
versailles et à l'arrestation de ces
deux auteurs lundi dernier avec les deux
auteurs de l'attentât de versailles
c'est finalement huit personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui déférés devant la cour de
sûreté de l'état
selon les policiers c'est la branche
d'ille-et-vilaine tout entière de
l'armée révolutionnaire bretonne qui
serait ainsi démantelé à son actif 27
attentes a reconnu depuis 18 mois
notamment ceux contre le relais de
télévision de pré-en-pail et contre la
cité administrative de renault dans ce
cas particulier nous avons été piégés
nous savons maintenant puisque
on trouvait que les perquisitions et les
arrestations des postes de radio bricolé
par nos adversaires et qui leur
permettait de suivre tous les toutes les
opérations de police s'étaient dirigés
contre eux en fait qu'ils écoutaient nos
émissions de police de façon parfaite et
continue déjouant ainsi aisément les
filatures qui était l'objet est
évidemment ça explique que nous soyons
retraite
nous venons été très souvent pris à
contre-pied ces ouvrages qu'elle la
coloration politique des 6000 personnes
c'est à ses voisins de l'arc en ciel en
fait on a dansé dansé du personnage le
garçon et qui ont affiché voici quelques
années des applis en très à gauche
d'autres qui sont des descendants ou
voir des relations de
d'anciens membres de la milice perrotte
7 gestapo française et bretonne gallas
qui l'avait
que la brouille avec les allemands en
traquant existants et non quelques
membres se sont réfugiés vivent toujours
actuellement en allemagne
nous avons des gens qui sont plutôt
traditionnellement située à droite
enfin c'est un assemblage très
hétéroclite qu'on peut absolument pas si
triste dans un horizon politique voilà
pour le titre numéro un français qui a
fait l'ouverture du journal de la bbc il
ya une heure et qui intéressera bon
nombre de pêcheurs français c'est
l'interdiction de la pêche au hareng sur
toutes les côtes anglaises de monde et
on marchait comme on aujourd'hui
d'autoriser un arrêt total de la pêche
de harangues de large de l'ecosse pour
protéger cette espèce très convoitée et
qui risque de disparaître les cols du
jour était un des hauts lieux de la
pêche du avant mais depuis des années
les pêcheurs surtout grâce aux
techniques modernes ont carrément piller
la mer il y a de moins en moins de
harengs ici dans le port de malek qui
était le port le plus important d'europe
pour la pêche du hareng la forte hausse
des prix a longtemps protéger les
pêcheurs contre la baisse des prises
maintenant il faut aller plus loin et
interdire la pêche pendant au moins
trois ans
c'est ce que le gouvernement britannique
envisage pour mardi prochain au marché
aux poissons le prix les prix ont grimpé
de plus de 800 francs par tonne la
semaine dernière et on se dépêcher
d'acheter les derniers à rang lorsque
les harengs seront vendus en l'orne par
exemple ils coûteront jusqu'à 9 francs
pièce pour les pêcheurs écossais la
responsabilité de cette pénurie incombe
aux bateaux des autres pays du marché
commun
s'il n'y avait que des écossais distille
les harengs ne serait pas menacée de
disparition europe toujours toute
l'italie respire ce soir son petit marot
et libre à elle avait fini par adopter
ce petit garçon de 11 ans depuis didier
une semaine le pape avait révélé son
drame sur la place saint pierre
marolleau car à sa lettre et est offert
en otage à la place de son frère son
frère aîné gravement malade
les mains de ses ravisseurs s'apprêtait
à enlever sous les yeux de son père par
la suite c'est l'attitude des
kidnappeurs fut tout à fait odieuse ils
refusèrent une première fois de libérer
marot après avoir reçu une rançon de 100
g
millions de lires la famille double à la
somme et le petit garçon fut donc
libérerait la nuit dernière
tous les italiens garderont en mémoire
les phrases de paul 6 marot nous sommes
avec toi tu es le symbole de la bonté et
de vie naissance puis quatrième gros
titres de l'actualité le liban faux
espoirs cette nuit le cessez le feu aura
été de courte durée
les tirs d'armes de tous calibres ont
repris ce matin contre les quartiers
chrétiens de beyrouth ainsi donc
l'accord intervenu hier soit entre élias
sarkis le président libanais et le chef
de l'état syrien hafez el assad
aura-t-il été immédiatement violé et les
libanais se retrouve confronté avec une
violence comparable à celle des pires
moments de la guerre civile
c'est un déluge de fer de feu qui s'abat
depuis hier sur achrafié le quartier
chrétien de beyrouth
les soldats syriens ont véritablement
matraquer le secteur en utilisant toutes
sortes d'armements lourds cannes ou
orgue de staline
plusieurs hôpitaux ont été touchés par
les tirs
ce qui étonne c'est l'acharnement
aujourd'hui des forces syriennes contre
les chrétiens phalangistes c'est
pourtant il y a deux ans pour les sortir
d'une situation militaire difficile que
les syriens étaient entrés au liban
contre les palestiniens les
progressistes libanais ce retournement
s'expliquerait par le désir de la syrie
de contrôle est véritablement toute la
zone chrétienne mais aussi peut-être
pour empêcher une alliance encore plus
importante des conservateurs chrétiens
avec israël
une alliance entre certains chrétiens
israéliens créent de plus en plus
visibles dans les enclaves chrétiennes
du sud liban où des phalangistes de
pierre gemayel sont également implantés
ces bombardements aveugles serait donc
une sorte d'avertissement pourquoi les
phalangistes n'aille pas plus loin et ne
pâtissent pas avec israël le président
syrien a d'ailleurs condamné tous ceux
au liban qui accepte le dialogue avec
israël ce que redoutent damas c'est que
ces enclaves chrétiennes nous devienne
un autre front dans le dos de l'armée
syrienne
les enclaves chrétiennes du sud liban
sont devenus de véritables forteresses
grâce surtout aux matériels très
importants que les israéliens ont laissé
aux miliciens chrétiens après leur
départ oui est sûre c'est israël qui est
appliquée qui a fait tout quoi
je vais créer donc une milice il n'y
avait pas eu d israéliens les villages
auraient été piétinée de tous les côtés
on ne cache pas ici que les véritables
protecteurs sont les israël bien ces
petites enclaves n'ont pu subsister
économiquement et militairement que
grâce à israël
après l'invasion du sud-liban et l'envoi
des casques bleus de l'onu les chrétiens
ont élargi leurs pancartes formant la
première ligne de défense d'israël
contre les palestiniens
il refuse d'abandonner leurs positions
militaires et entendent continuer leur
collaboration avec les histoires non
maintenant on accepte personnes dans
notre région
absolument des sandales ni l'armée ni la
fouille les unit feu on accepte personne
absolument le centre caf
premièrement les uniformes les lions du
feu ne peuvent rien de protéger vers la
porte aux chrétiens qui s'enrhume au
liban premièrement deuxièmement l'armée
libanaise qui va venir au sud
je vois que ce n'est pas l'armée
libanaise c'est l'armée syrienne plus
tôt il existe comme une armée libanaise
il existe mais sans la vache folle pour
la série up pour le liban est ce qui
économiquement vous n'avez pas non plus
les problèmes de vivre comme ça dans un
espèce donc l'avenant comment
réussissez-vous à vivre
cet incident et je ne peux pas vous dire
et vous par le coeur d'israël nous nous
a donné des choses par exemple les
lettres les vêtements militaires ne nous
a donné aussi
les fusées les dingues
voyez les blancs des sceaux du tout les
choses militaires rangés
quoi de mieux pour illustrer l'autorité
des milices chrétiennes au sud liban
mais aussi l'impossibilité des forces
des nations unies y est entré c'est
cette discussion à laquelle nous avons
participé en tant qu'interprète entre un
commandant de la force des nations unies
qui ne parlait qu'anglais
l'officier chrétiens qui lui ne parlait
que le français il veut aller voir louis
racine sy votre commande
il a dit qu'il avait déjà vu et que et
qu'il voudrait encore lui parler qu'est
ce que je lui réponds
sans arme et sans harcèlement de l'autre
donc je lui dis ça je les traduis çà et
là
finalement donc ces soldats des nations
unies ont pu entrer sans armes et est
accompagné par un milicien chrétien
vous voyez que les journalistes peuvent
votre autre chose que de simple témoin
toujours au proche-orient dernière
journée aujourd'hui de la visite du goût
de mondial en israël le vice président
américain a rencontré ce matin le
premier ministre israélienne or on
disait après le massacre des treize
blank dans une mission l'art est belle
de mugabe et l'opposant au régime aux
récidives et ont tous en 14 noir hier
les guérilléros sont dit aux ouvriers
agricoles noirs qu'il ne devait pas
travailler pour les blancs puis les ont
enfermés dans leurs casiers ont mis le
feu
parmi les victimes une femme et ses cinq
enfants âgés de 2 à 10 ans le but des
extrémistes est de démontrer que le plan
de monsieur jan smith qui accepte de
céder le pouvoir une majorité noire très
modérée était réalisable
le commentateur de la bbc estime que ce
n'est pas là le meilleur moyen de
convaincre monsieur smith de discuter
avec eux mais par leur politique de
terreur des rebelles de mugabe ont
réussi à chasser les fermiers blancs de
la région
souhaid nouvelles tentatives de
coordination des européens pour lutter
contre la trobe christian bonnet mais
les crises et leurs sept collègues
ministres à delonte ailleurs se sont
réunis aujourd'hui à stockhom états unis
retour de richard nixon sur la scène
politique pour la première fois depuis
sa démission
et là parler au public et on a profité
pour critiquer à moi ou à les gimmicks
art
je suis parti républicain rassemblés
dans la petite ville de haydn dans les
montagnes du kentucky au sud des états
unis
le show nixon a reproché aux prisés en
carter ne pas savoir s'y prendre avec
les russes d'être trop dures en paroles
et trop mou lorsqu'ils négocient les
admirateurs de monsieur nixon sont des
inconditionnels les uns vous allez voir
ont interrompu leurs vacances pour venir
voir le plus grand président des états
unis
comme dit la femme de ce monsieur un
autre interrogé par un reporter de la
bbc répond que watergate
il n'y croit pas lui
retour en france pour quelques nouvelles
brèves dans le domaine social reprise du
travail demain dans les arsenaux la
suite d'un vote après trois semaines de
grève début des négociations salariales
à la sncf aujourd'hui et demain la
métallurgie c'est pour vendredi
et puis calendrier toujours mais
calendrier politique une semaine chargée
souvent en effet avec beaucoup d'allées
et venues en perspective alayli roger
chinaud le président du groupe udf à
l'assemblée nationale accompagnera jean
le cannet tous deux commenceront cette
série d'entretiens demain 18h le même
principe a été adopté pour toutes les
rencontres
deux invités pour chaque parti ou
mouvement son responsable nationale et
le président du groupe à l'assemblée
c'est ainsi que claude labbé gravira les
marches de l'elysée en même temps que
jacques chirac ont dit ou rpr il sera
avant tout question de l'entrée de
l'espagne dans le marché commun le
lendemain mercredi sera consacrée à
l'opposition en début d'après-midi
gaston defferre sera avec françois
mitterrand pour le parti socialiste
enfin pour clôturer ces rencontres
robert ballanger deviendra seul georges
marchais est absente paris les
communistes ont ailleurs très sceptique
quant à l'intérêt de ces visites
le tout constitue donc la deuxième série
d'entretiens décrisper de l'elysée la
première ayant eu lieu à la fin du mois
de mars les affaires sociales maintenant
mais judici l'angleterre tout le monde
le sait traverse une mauvaise passe sur
le plan économique et de nouveau les
syndicats s'agite parmi eux le plus dur
celui qui n'a pas hésité il ya quelques
années à faire tomber le gouvernement
hills
le syndicat des mineurs réunis pour le
congrès annuel à tort qu'il est mineur
qui préfèrent leur prochain négociations
salariales au millionnaire le
gouvernement celui-ci veut modérer leurs
demandes
mais les mineurs se sont fâchés on vous
mêlez pas de nos affaires a dit à peu
près jean camille le président du
syndicat des mineurs laissez nous régler
nous-mêmes nos problèmes avec les
directions des nine
le gouvernement ne doit pas intervenir
sinon nous nous opposerons directement
le gouvernement
l'entente est une expérience comparer
les regarde antennes de la bbc sur le
même événement l'événement question
c'est le 50e anniversaire du droit de
vote pour les femmes ici les anglaises
avaient en effet vingt ans d'avancé sur
les françaises voici donc les cérémonies
commémoratives vu par philippe chatenet
pour antenne 2 et d'abord prakash
marchande manille pour la bbc
elles sont peut-être un est libre mais
il a fallu de longues années de lutte
pour obtenir le droit de vote
l'avant-garde était représenté par
connie locke & key incendié une guerre
et menaçaient de faire exploser la
cathédrale de durham chalet williams
ministre de l'éducation rappelle le sens
de la lutte
c'est au niveau supérieur dans les
industries maintenant les syndicats que
les femmes n'ont pas réussi leur percée
qu'elle méritait de faire des membres du
mouvement de libération de la femme
expriment leur colère
nous ne voulons plus être représenté sur
les affiches dans les journaux à la télé
au cinéma comme des symboles sexuels ou
maternelle ou comme des femmes de ménage
dureront une semaine
certains pensent qu'il faudra peut-être
encore 50 ans pour que les femmes les
hommes et des droits égaux
une ouverture en fanfare par la musique
des abords est ce pour le cinquantenaire
du iqal frenchies hat qui a donné le
droit de vote aux femmes britten
la cause féministe en angleterre a
justement connu la semaine dernière une
nouvelle victoire quand un tribunal a
reconnu à teresa bennett une écolière de
12 ans le droit de jouer au football
avec les garçons
il y avait environ 200 personnes venues
écouter musique et discours sur le gazon
devant le parlement
toutes les générations de femmes
britanniques étaient représentés puisque
à côté des avocettes il y avait la
vieille garde les suffragettes et
notamment ronnie look up le voici qui
avaient incendié une gare et tenter de
faire sauter une cathédrale
rachel rogers une jeune fille qui fait
elle son 18e anniversaire âge auquel on
devient électrices et électeurs ici a
déposé une gerbe au pied de la statue
des mailings pankhurst l'héroïne de la
longue lutte des suffragettes qui
s'enchaîner aux grilles du parlement et
donc plus de mille furent emprisonnés
au cours des 50 ans qui ont suivi cette
conquête du droit de vote
les femmes britanniques qui d'ailleurs
sont plus nombreuses que les hommes ont
beaucoup progressé notamment grâce à une
loi de 1975 qui garantit aux femmes un
salaire égal pour un travail égal et qui
bannit toute discrimination sexuelle
il reste toutefois du chemin à parcourir
avant l'égalité complète entre les
anglais et les anglaises
les revendications portent surtout sur
les salaires la promotion
professionnelle les droits civiques
d'où une frange d'extrémistes du mlf
comme celle ci qui prône la guerre à
outrance contre l'establishment masculin
lequel ne semble pas trop s'en émeut
voit d'ailleurs dans ce parlement devant
lequel avait lieu la célébration du
cinquantenaire
il n'ya aujourd'hui sur 635 députés que
27 femmes autre expérience pour essayer
de changer vos habitudes
c'est une équipe anglaise que nous avons
chargé du courrier est un phénomène très
suprenant vous de londres
je veux parler de vos de parts aux
vacances et aux sons vont des millions
et des millions de français mouton le
voiture et fonce vers l'ouest vers le
sud vers l'espagne vers l'italie les
conséquences de ce département ce peut
être
en vérité spectaculaire le pire leur
cote c'était en août 1975
on a estimé à plusieurs millions de
livres le coût des heures gaspillé dont
les embouteillages colossaux des litres
d'essence brûlé dans les bouchons
les choses se sont apparemment améliorée
depuis trois ans mais cette année comme
d'habitude les titres de la presse et
radio et de la télé sont plaints
d'avertissements et de pronostics et les
français se précipitent et partent ils
partent sous l'égide de ce mot sur siph
rouge évidemment qui s'appelle bison
foot est en anglais kraft va falloir
c'est lui le fer de lance de la campagne
menée par les pouvoirs publics afin de
régulariser ce flot cette marée de
voitures qui envahissent les autoroutes
et les axes principaux dont tous ses
week-ends l'on est affreux du début est
un des moins de juillet et août nous
nous trouvons maintenant hop et c'est au
centre nerveux de bison futé est la
salle de contrôle de ronnie dans la
banlieue parisienne
ici on serait le flot de la circulation
dans toute la france en outre les lieux
où elle devient trop dont ce qui si on a
déjà conseillé aux gens d'éviter à tout
prix
certains ceux de départ certaines routes
on a déjà établi toute une série de
routes supplémentaires
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres marquée
d'une façon que moi je trouve
déconcertant retardé par une flèche
verte qui ressemble à un cercueil on se
prépare pour ce premier grand week-end
de la saison des vacances les français
sont vent derrière ils laissent des
cités et des villes à moitié abandonnée
surtout en août aux touristes aux
fusions au malheureux qui pour quelque
raison que ce soit ne peuvent pas partir
car ça c'est l'autre côté des comptes et
pas les évacuations des bills par
exemple plusieurs fois par semaine je
déjeune à seurre vous
resteront incroyable du quartier près de
mon bureau ou comme il faut la carte
écrite à l'autre violette
ici on se restaure avec peut-être un
poteau fort ou un steak frites avec du
beaujolais mais hélas dans ce long mois
de juillet j'aurai à chercher ailleurs
fermeture annuelle congés annuels les
pros cap fleuriste dont les fenêtres des
magasins des cafés des resteront mais
pourquoi faut-il qu'ils partent les
français tous ensemble on a parlé au
niveau gouvernemental d'étaler les
départs mais les traditions conspirent
contre le changement et j'ai parfois
l'impression que ces bouchons c'est à
ton sont devenues partie du folklore des
vacances du peuple de france
steven chasse aux ondes de bbc
merci à nos amis anglais baissier de
parler comme ça le français n'ont pas
tellement l'habitude j'ajoute que si les
autonomistes anglais sont plus âgés plus
disciplinés que les nôtres vous l'avez
vu leurs enfants prennent moins de
vacances que leurs petits camarades
français ça vient de là vers le point
fait sa couverture sur ce chiffre
étonnant 216 jours de vacances 149 jours
d'école et sur ses 216 jours de repos en
france on compte 120 jours fériés en
angleterre il y à un mois de moins tout
juste 80 à 90 jours fériés en moyenne
sport maintenant avec l'événement roi du
mois le tennis les haras nationaux de
wimbledon roger couderc écoutez après
chez les dames après le résultat
enregistre aujourd'hui on relève un
match qui va faire de bruit en quarts de
finale
chris evert états unis ancien champion
de wimbledon première joueuse du monde
contre billie jean king qui est
également américain qui a également
remporté wimbledon va faire du bruit
horrible étonnant chez les hommes chez
les hommes un week-end de finale notons
les victoires aujourd'hui d'anastase qui
a encore fait le pitre mais qui d'abord
est café qui vraiment amusé tout il le
donne et puis de connors bien sûr
dockers et de bjorn borg
bien entendu mais ne marche plus
attendus aujourd'hui c'était celui
opposant roulera me reste mexicain à
l'australien john nous comme ac
vainqueur à wimbledon qui effectue son
grand retour après à 34 ans
ce match le dernier jeu de ce match
d'ailleurs que poesy raul ramires à john
newcombe l'australien nous qu'on mette
au service et humaine le temps 30 0
ramirez est au service et y mène 30-0
il a gagné le premier set 6 2 le
deuxième 9,8 et y mène 5-3 dans ce
troisième et dernier set bons signaux
comme ramirez au service à tous les deux
des moustaches et oui non mais l'idée de
doha bies la drogue de cheveux beaucoup
plus long voyez que nous comme a déjà
manqué lourde
il a 34 ans ramires lui est en pleine
forme ville durant dix ans à nous qu'on
40 0 là quatre balles de match une seule
suffira la première mais sera belle
regarder
on peut continuer à voir la dernière
balle c'est fini s'il demeure 8 6 3
ramires grandes vacances
de l'autre côté de la manche maintenance
4e étape du tour de france étape un peu
spéciale puisque courue par équipes et
vous allez le voir c'est l'équipe
alec tei qui l'a emporté de peu devant
l'équipe c'est à dire deux équipes
patronné par les entreprises anglaises
qui prouve l'intérêt croissant des
anglais pour cette course et je vous
laisse découvrir donc l'équipe pays qui
arrive en ce moment les dix coureurs en
tout cas ils ont parcouru l'étape oeuvre
quand à près de 42 kilomètres à l'heure
de moyenne changement de maillot jaune
en conséquence c'est l'allemand à
l'heure qui prend son paletot jaune au
français au 6/9 man second classement
général une possède le belge bruyères à
46 secondes et baucis à une minute voici
donc le nouveau maillot jaune l'allemand
thaler et puis ils se portent toujours
football c'est que les anglais n'ont pas
eu le droit de participer à la coupe du
monde ils ont été éliminés mais et loire
comment avec humour ils ont pris leur
revanche pour bébé il pénètre dans la
défense adverse
le goal il va marquer c'est charbon
c'est un merveilleux but de basile
leterrier 1 0 le public est ravi et
legault doit grimper sur ses buts pour
éviter la colère des équipes riches
remise à nous aux vip le collège qui par
endroits
c'est une bagarre qui déclina c'est une
bagarre voilà le genre de spectacle on
peut plus voir sur un terrain de
football de nos génies l'a8 intervient
appelle le joueur lors de ses passes et
un carton jaune
c'est un avertissement avertissement non
non c'est un carton rouge l'arbitré du
joueur pour brutalité et le renvoie aux
vestiaires corps et à l'esprit
l'égalisation magnifique tête grippe qui
a placé le ballon en pleine lucarne
magnifique but dissipe la fin sur cette
attaque mettant un terme à cette
excellente partie qui se termine sur un
score nul c'était un extrait d'une
émission de la bbc qui s'appelle date là
est ce que vous avez pu voir en
intégrale dans l'émission de lotbinière
cet après midi vous avez encore un autre
rendez vous avec l'angleterre tout de
suite après le journal notre nouvelle
speakerine michel mallet vous en dira
plus mais sachez d'ores et déjà que vous
y verrez la plus vieille émission
anglaise de variétés de good old days
tous les spectateurs qui assistent
déguisés en costumes 1900 et sont à eux
seuls croit la moitié du spectacle
mais avant d'en arriver là la météo
temps inégale en france aujourd'hui 26
degrés à marseille contre 20 degrés à
paris nancy et rennes demain et bien il
fera beau et chaud sur toute la moitié
sud du pays au nord ciel couvert avec
plus intermittentes surtout de la
bretagne à la frontière belge
si cela peut vous consoler il fera
mauvais en angleterre aussi au temps
froid avec des grosses averses sur le
plupart des régions voilà c'était le
journal en direct de londres
bonsoir actu bonsoir patrick bonsoir
angela votre prochain rendez vous et
tout à l'heure à 23h avec hervé claude
moi je vous retrouve demain participants
soir à tous